when I some was like I was seeing a
ghost like every trigger I've ever
pulled
howdy start you hunting birds rabbit
guessing 19 20 years old the first time
he ordered you to shoot a person
25 years ago he took my blood
made you from me
has been lying to you the whole time
told you you were an orphan and all the
people in the world to come after me why
would he send you
because I'm the best you are obviously
not the best and just trying to rattle
me trying to save you you made a choice
to do this to me the whole point of this
thing was to give you all of Henry's
gifts without his pain I don't want to
shoot you
fine if I shoot you Henry is this ever
having you before your own government
trying to kill you wow that's new
[Music]
everything that we've worked for is a
stake he has to die
he's your darkness you had to walk
through this on your own I love you
Junior
look what we created
you're the inspiration for all of us
when I just make a whole army full of
them why not you should be flattered you
should be dead
this has to be stopped
because what if somebody actually know
what we really are
you